[Music]
today's question comes from adam in
alabama
my wife and i have two sides to our
business one is catering and the other
is full-service restaurant we started
these businesses three years ago and
they are debt free with kovitz still
prevalent we have taken a significant
hit with low sales supply chain issues
and staffing problems
my wife ties her identity and self-worth
to the success of this business but i
would be glad to close it down she wants
to take a loan to keep us afloat and i'm
not in agreement with this plan
should i hold on and struggle and even
go into debt i know the answer is no but
how can i do it when my spouse is
against me
and afraid of the future
well there's a lot going on here um
a lot i mean the the obvious is you and
your spouse need to get on the same page
regardless of what you do and you know
adam that we're we're never gonna tell
you to take out a loan
um
but even if you don't take out a loan
and even regardless of what path you
take with the business you still need to
get on the same page with your spouse
you and your wife need to get on the
same page of the vision get to the root
of what her fears are what she's
struggling with and so on the other
thing is just from a business standpoint
i can't help but
want to dig into that and go okay what's
the real problem yeah you may be having
some struggles and yes some of it is
covid but is there a way to say okay
we're gonna
maybe shut down the restaurant and go
all in on catering or maybe we're going
to
downsize a little bit scale back to
where because we have staffing issues
we're going to do just the pieces that
we can do ourselves or you know i just i
like to problem solve but sometimes when
you're just
sad or scared or overwhelmed uh it it
feels bigger than it is it feels more
impossible than it is actually put that
on instagram today
you know
sometimes when you're overwhelmed things
just feel
bigger scarier and more impossible than
they actually are so i wonder if some of
these are not
very fixable problems adam that if you
could fix these problems
the business could do better the sales
would improve you don't have to take out
a loan obviously which we're not going
to tell you to do and
you and your spouse can get on the same
page for the vision um
you know and obviously her identity
doesn't need to be attached to it but as
a business owner you know this dave like
you you can't totally emotionally
separate yourself from the success of
the business because it is your baby
there's an aspect of it that's
that's healthy and then you don't want
it to be well my sole source of identity
is here we know that so
it's a lot it's a lot's going on i feel
like in this question yeah it's
unhealthy
to not tie some of your identity and
some of your
uh self-worth to your business because
you're pouring yourself
into it
and to completely detach from that would
make you a psychopath yeah you care and
so you actually care about it and it's
it's my thing it's like it's something i
poured a lot into so it'd be unhealthy
to do that what i don't like hearing is
she ties her identity and self-worth to
the success
of the business so what you have to do
is you have to back yourself up and say
okay
there are some things in this that i can
control
for those things i'm going to tie my
some of my self-worth
and some of my identity to it and i'm
going to get my butt in gear and i'm
going to push some stuff around and make
it happen because i care right
uh then there's things you can't control
you can't make people
come to work
in the restaurant business right now
when they're being paid to sit at home
by the stupid federal government
everywhere you go high-end low-end
restaurants and anything that is service
industry is struggling with labor
shortage
because they're sitting at home
until the federal government stops that
i mean that's just that's not something
you'd caused so i'm not gonna if i'm you
i'm not gonna go oh i did something
wrong i feel bad about me
i can't get labor and so we have to
scale this back to the labor that i can
get which is me and thee right and um
and whatever else i mean
however many kids we had whatever we're
we're all gonna be in here working but i
can't make anybody else work yeah um and
i can't make
a supply chain stuff be right right i
can't make i mean we're we're fighting
scratching with these paper people
there's a paper shortage now get these
books out
your books are in coleman's books around
we got books scheduled for january i'm
buying paper form now
because i know that we got a supply
chain problem so but i can't say oh
there's a paper shortage and so i feel
bad about me
no i feel that there's a paper shortage
right
i don't need to feel bad nothing had to
do with it my identity's not tied to
that so
it gets real cliche but sometimes pieces
of something have to die for something
to grow or even the whole thing dies for
something to grow back where there's
this much manure there's plenty of
opportunity to grow
that's for sure
and we've had the same thing around here
kiddo i mean we've been pivoting so much
i feel like i'm just chasing a dog
chasing its tail uh changing stuff and
moving things around how we deliver
products and you know what a book tour
used to look like to what it looks like
today there's not one now we do it all
virtual uh because the people in new
york have lost their ever-loving minds
in the media world uh what it you know
they want us to
like put our first born in a vault or
something just to go see them and it's
just like you people are nuts forget it
and so no you're not going to extract my
dna for me to come into your studio
you've lost your dad gum mines so we
have to we have to adjust and pivot the
whole thing
and so
um
uh uh
i think that this is god whispering to
your wife
to get this business
in its proper perspective within her
psyche
because it's gonna kill her if it
succeeds
and and it owns her
it'll ride her into the grave yeah if it
fails and it owns her it'll ride her
into the grave so she's got to get back
on top of it and start owning it there's
nothing wrong we're confirming that you
should care deeply we're confirming that
it should
hurt your feelings
that you that your business that you
built is failing to do to nothing that
you did wrong
i mean you've got government
interference
you've got economic interference labor
shortages and supply chain shortages you
did nothing wrong
it hurts your feelings and you grieve
that as deloney would say yeah
and you know all of that is is normal
but i think this is the opportunity to
not to take out a loan but instead to
decide who owns what there's a business
owned here she own it
and if she owns it she can close part of
it
i own this
i don't want to close any of it it's too
that gum hard to open but i will close
it and then i'll still be here
i'll still be here
and i'll still be whole
and i'll be sad yeah but um but uh you
know if we shut down something that i
love here
because it doesn't work anymore i'll be
sad i've done it before i've closed down
the whole uh business units here yeah
that that just didn't work and i had
invested millions of dollars and a lot
of my emotion into and it hurts
but i'm also still here yeah because i
own it it doesn't own me and really i
think that's the core atom of what you
all got to do it's not about do i go
along with my spouse the answer is no
you don't go along with your spouse
because your spouse is not functioning
well here is what you're saying yeah and
i like how you made that distinction too
of you're going to control what you can
control and we always say this but
control which you can control what does
that look like in light of the problems
you're facing what you can do what you
can fix what is right for you given
everything you're coming up against and
those things that you can't control you
can't you let those go and you separate
your identity and your self-worth from
all these outside challenges that have
nothing to do with you that you didn't
do
and i just think that's a really helpful
distinction yeah i i cannot control what
the biden administration does
they may close me down
they may put me out of business i can't
control it i can't control what they do
the only thing i can control is what i
can control and that's me yeah and
whether i st whether i stand whether i
stand on principle whether i'm a person
of integrity uh and whether i've done
the best i can do with what was in front
of me and then sometimes
it still doesn't work yeah
yep and out of that is always born out
of those ashes as a phoenix always rises
up out and it's very cliche but there's
a reason for those cliches is it happens
happens all the time the death of a
relationship is the birth of something
new the death of
of a business is the birth of a new idea
out of those ashes it happens all the
time
if you own it
instead of it owning you